the bedroom yeah i don't get that one no
you're welcome no i i'm sorry i
i don't have well what can i say all
right my talk on the table is a sequel
to yesterday if you recall when we uh
with regarding uh david chang
who um we showed you how he picked up a
million dollars
to help struggling restaurant workers
take a look i'm going to go
final answer b
benjamin harrison final answer
he grabbed his
[Music]
your metallic testicles
just won you a million dollars for your
show
jimmy kimmel dragged it out chang's the
first celebrity to win the top prize on
who wants to be a millionaire
the money is going to his mother
southern smoke foundation
which provides crisis relief for people
in the food and beverage industry
its co-founder chris shepherd was
watching sunday night
the foundation's emergency relief fund
has given more than four million dollars
during the pandemics of more than
2 000 people and david chang joins us
now good morning
i was really worried about you there was
so much pressure on you
in that moment and i could see how much
it meant to you to get this money for
these people
it was incredibly stressful but i'm so
happy it worked out for everybody
how did you go for that david because
you had five hundred thousand if you
would stop then was that what you're
going to say yeah
it would fall to 32 000 if you if you if
you got it left it alone you would have
500 000
if you missed you would have gone down
to 32 but
how did you decide to go for it when you
weren't totally sure
i don't i have no explanation because
watching it from
my like couch i was like this person is
crazy i have no idea why i did
whatever i did but i'm glad that it
happened and i think i made the
calculation that
uh i never i'm trusting mina number one
and two
if i got it wrong it was still gonna put
a spotlight on southern smoke and the
sort of crisis that hospitality workers
are facing but
uh i was really uh trusting nina kind's
intelligence and
and uh smarts she's right you reached
out her and she
and she gave you uh you asked her for
her input but i think what she said it
was
probably harrison so she wasn't like a
sure thing i was like boy you're relying
on this a lot
but but david talk to us about i mean
where you think the restaurant industry
is right now because
you're trying to help people and you
were here with us right at the beginning
of this pandemic
and extremely distressed about the way
things were headed
yeah i mean things haven't gotten that
much better um effectively with winter
here outdoor dining is shut down for a
lot of places and
uh even if the weather is nice here and
i'm in los angeles right now and outdoor
dining is shut down
at least for three weeks or so so that's
going to be incredibly difficult for our
restaurants to get to the new year
and i think the goal amongst my peer
group is just to get to spring so it's a
matter of survival
and and as crazy as it sounds the most
important thing that
we can do to save restaurants besides
supporting them
directly is to probably and possibly
support the election in
georgia and flip the senate seats to
maybe get
congress to give us the stimulus and to
support the restaurant workers and
hourly workers and everyone that needs
help
so david why did he say you have
metallic testicles i'm just curious
is it something you can share on morning
tv or not if
you're not because i can move on you're
on the mantle behind you you can't
no i mean listen okay i i i
i have no idea i i i i i i i i
i i heard a funny story about you david
chang that you know people but yet you
forgot to get thanksgiving turkey how
could that possibly be
and you're a chef how could that be
yes hang your hands i have to ask my
wife it's sort of the one thing she
requested
and uh i got i won't say lazy i
i wanted to make an alternative and uh
but you know
i was a little late and i'll make it up
to her next year
tell us what southern smoke does though
i thought it was really great that you
chose that charity how
how will it help the workers anthony
touched on it a bit
i think it's great what you've done and
i loved his reaction the founder's
reaction when he saw that you had
chosen them well chris is a great chef
and
someone that is constantly trying to
take care of his own and the own being
the hospitality industry and
it has been hit the hardest or one of
the hardest sectors
from the pandemic and
you know everyone needs help in this
business and and southern smoke has
always been there
for whatever crisis that has arisen over
the past few years to
provide financial assistance to people
in need and
uh they need them more than ever so but
at least now people will know about
it and i'm curious sitting on the show
does it feel
different because you missed it what was
it the uh
kids um clean plate club before
yeah i actually didn't know that answer
because what was what was the question
david what was the question what was the
question
it was it was something like uh what is
it called what club do kids uh
you know put themselves in if they eat
all their food and you know
watching from home of course i know the
answer but when you're sitting in the
seat
yeah staring at jimmy kimmel and the
lights are on you
and the music the music is what gets
your adrenaline really pumping
and you sort of lose all trait of
thought so and jimmy did
made a point of underlying the fact that
no celebrity had ever
won the big prize that's right yeah i
think he said it twice
well yeah i think jimmy knows that i i
like to gamble
and he knew that he could sort of poke
and brought me to
going for the final question for sure
yeah well congratulations
really great i'm so happy to see it uh
and that money is certainly well
sorely needed and we'll go to a great
what are you going to do with that big
old check where is that
is that is that behind you you can't
take it to the bank
it is a no i can't take in the bank i
think i'm going to put it on my wall
when i